this guy's
probably fought hundreds of thousands of
other super beings on the other planets
he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's one i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new justice league
snyder cut video for all the new scenes
that they just announced there's a bunch
of big news about all the dc movies
including batman stuff so we'll break it
all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you're most hyped
up to see
in the snyder cut so just starting with
number five big stuff first
zack snyder and warner brothers
announced that they're bringing back
most of the main cast of the justice
league actors to film
brand new scenes for the justice league
snyder cut this fall pretty soon
actually
they've already been working on
completing the movie all year already
but this is a big deal actually bringing
back ben affleck as batman for brand new
scenes
years after they filmed the original
movie deadline variety hollywood
reporter all the big hollywood trade
publications are reporting that it's ben
affleck coming back for new batman
scenes gal gadot's wonder woman
aquaman in cyborg and that's it they
didn't list
ezra miller's flash or henry cavill so
that means that whatever zack snyder is
doing with the flash during the snyder
cut he already has all the footage of
him that he needs
henry cavill also just did an interview
recently after this announcement was
made because he has a netflix movie
that's out this week with millie bobby
brown from stranger things
and per him he's already filmed all the
superman scenes for the snyder cut that
were necessary
way back when zack snyder was originally
filming the movie in 2016 and 2017
and on top of that they finally revealed
a more correct estimate for the actual
budget
of the justice league snyder cut movie
and it's way bigger than a lot of the
trades reported earlier this year
so number four most of you just want to
know what the new batman scenes are
going to be new wonder woman
aquaman cyborg the way the trades are
reporting the announcement the reshoots
themselves are only going to last for
around a week maybe a little bit more
and even though i only mentioned those
four justice league actors coming back
to do new scenes
there will be a bunch of minor
background actors and lesser characters
all the headlines this past week were
really just about ben affleck coming
back as batman for new scenes with the
others
but when you do reshoots there's always
a bunch of stuff going on in the
background of scenes too but the only
types of scenes that they can finish in
under a week like they're doing right
now are
mostly just smaller character moments
where they're talking to each other
in exposition scenes like smaller
character moments the news reports also
didn't specify whether or not the main
justice league actors would be coming
back for their new scenes at the same
time
like if the new scenes will have all of
them together in the scenes talking to
each other
some of the scenes are probably them
just dipping in for a day or two here
and there in
separate new scenes it's really common
for smaller reshoots like this to happen
when they're editing the movie together
and they find that they need extra
dialogue or small moments to connect to
other scenes like wonder woman learns
the secrets of dark side in this old
greek temple and you get that flashback
scene
then maybe the cut suddenly jumps to
batman talking about darkseid they would
need a quick scene of wonder woman
telling batman who darkseid is between
those two scenes
to have it all make sense so that's
where your reshoots come in
also there's all the cyborg stuff cyborg
is kind of a special case in the snyder
cut because if you've been listening to
all the streams that zack snyder has
been doing between comic con and the
other conventions this year talking
about the movie
cyborg is supposed to be one of the most
important characters to the story
and he's barely in the theatrical cut so
not only is there a whole deleted
subplot with his character we've seen
some of those new scenes in the snyder
cut trailer from dc fandom
but zack snyder probably needs more
cyborg scenes with each of the different
characters to help sew
everything together he said that cyborg
is supposed to be the heart of the movie
and one of the core people that brings
the justice league together
and if you want to be really optimistic
yes they could use that week to film a
new post credit scene as long as it's
not too
complicated i've already done videos
about the batman green lantern post
credit scene that zack snyder had
originally planned to do
i don't know if he was able to film any
of that back when he was first working
on the movie
or that's going to be some of the new
scenes that he adds back in and there
could be other green lantern stuff that
he does during the reshoots but usually
when people ask him what's going on with
green lantern during the movie he's been
pretty quiet about it just to avoid
giving away
really big spoilers number three this is
actually pretty exciting
the full budget that all the trades are
reporting for the movie is about
70 million dollars that's almost the
budget of the joker movie with joaquin
phoenix
very different kinds of movies though
the joker movie was almost like a small
indie movie by comparison
but that 70 million dollar figure is
more than double what the trades were
reporting the budget was
earlier this year that's a ton of extra
money and just to be clear that budget
isn't just for the reshoots that zack
snyder is doing that's for
everything in most of the budget
according to zack snyder himself is
going to be going to completing visual
effects the really hardcore stuff on the
footage he already filmed
but number two the other new batman
stuff that ben affleck is coming back
for is for the flash movie
flashpoint little bit different from
what's happening with him in the snyder
cut filming new scenes
andy muschietti is directing the flash
movie they're taking what zack snyder
did with the flash character creatively
in the justice league snyder cut and
then just building on that with some
creative changes and updates for the
flashpoint stuff
a lot of you said that you'd like to see
them fix the way that the flash runs
that's one of the things that they will
fix during the flash movie in addition
to giving him the new costume
in the quote about rebooting the dceu
that the flash movie producers gave say
that the movie will restart
quote-unquote everything but it doesn't
forget anything
so when they're talking about flashpoint
ben affleck's batman michael keaton's
batman
it means that they're going to be
changing some of the continuity in
service of bringing in the multiverse
and just retuning everything to add the
newer bigger movie characters that
they've added since the last justice
league movie like shazam and black adam
so that all the dc movies make sense
going forward
but i think it's important to remember
that they say that they're not
forgetting anything
and that's just the confirmation that
they're not completely retconning ben
affleck's batman away
if you're a big fan of his version of
the character i know there's some
hardcore fans out there that really want
him to come back for a batman hbo series
right now the only batman hbo series
that they've said that they're making is
matt reeves batman hbo series based on
the robber patents in batman movies
based on their production schedule they
probably won't end up releasing that
till
after the batman movie comes out next
year so we might see the tv show in
2022.
it'll take place during batman year one
in robert pattinson's gotham
the batman movie will take place during
batman year two so if the show runs for
multiple seasons
they'll just adjust the timeline of the
show so that it stays
in batman year one it's the exact same
thing that marvel is doing with the
avengers shows on disney plus like the
one division trailer that we just got
big movie crossovers with the tv shows
with the movie actors
appearing in their own shows the budgets
are way bigger than the cw dc tv shows
and they do way fewer episodes
there's a ton of dc shows coming to hbo
in the next few years they've only
announced
the batman series green lantern the new
suicide squad tv show
justice league dark a constantine tv
show
an aquaman tv show called king of
atlantis and there will be more but
those are just the ones that they've
talked about right now
you probably heard about them slowly
cancelling the cw dc tv shows that's
just because warner brothers is sort of
refocusing their attention on the big
budget
hbo dc tv shows but number one as for
the other cyborg stuff that's been
happening in the news there's been a lot
of cyborg in the news lately
despite all that the flash movie
producers say that he's still supposed
to appear in the flash movie in some way
but apparently part of the dispute that
they're having with ray fisher is about
how many
scenes he's supposed to have during the
movie i'm sure they'll eventually work
all that stuff out and cyborg will still
wind up at least having some sort of
cameo during the movie
but apparently before they decided to
bring back michael keaton's batman
cyborg was just a much bigger part of
the movie so it's easy to see
behind the scenes in warner brothers how
they swerved on that when they knew they
were going to get multiple
batman actors back during the movie
including ben affleck's batman
everyone let me know in the comments
though what else do you want them to do
during the new dc movies with their
different versions of batman if they
have
three now technically you still have ben
affleck's batman you have michael
keaton's batman
now you have robert pattinson's batman
as well we're all still waiting for
terry mcginnis to show up in a
live-action batman beyond which
supposedly they will be doing with
michael keaton's batman at some point in
the future so actually we'll have four
different versions of batman
everyone click here to re-watch the
batman trailer a billion more times and
click here for that brand new avengers 1
division trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]